you mentioned the word narrative that we
have to have a shared narrative now were
you saying that we have to have a shared
narrative
in order to have peace between us or in
order to interact
or in order to understand one another
and then also does that narrative have
to be
encapsulated in language or can it be
embodied because
i assume that animals can get along
and they don't have language at least
not the way we do and
presumably we didn't have language prior
to a million years ago
yeah we got along yeah when i meant it
in exactly the same
the sense that you um you intimated
there so
um yeah it it is just there if we
have a shared narrative that i'm i'm now
using narrative to describe a generative
model
that entails um sequences of things that
happen over time so it's a model of
sequences
um that usually has a deep deep temporal
structure to it
um so um if i want to understand you
and i want to communicate with you um in
order to understand you and to
and to ask you questions to understand
more about your
your intentional stance your knowledge
um then i'm going to need
to infer what you're thinking
and i can do that if i know what i'm
thinking
but only and then under the assumption
that you're using the same kind of model
as me
so we're both using the same code or
singing from the same hymn sheet
um so you know when you start to model
this you don't
you well we have models of of
linguistic exchange which are cast in
terms of
simple games of 20 questions so you know
one agent has to ask another agent
um through linguistic exchange but it
does depend
depend upon them both committing to the
same
generative model of this linguistic
exchange in the meaning
a simpler a simpler set of simulations
um um arises when you think about sort
of just birds singing to each other so
they can recognize con specifics
so you know what that's quite that's
much easier to simulate
when you just have two dynamical systems
talking to each other and they're both
now becoming trained to show
synchronization of chaos than we were
talking about before
in a different context but here in the
service of mutual predictability
so another way of thinking about what's
the best way to minimize surprise
surprise or self-information when
exchange with another
is to make sure that i only exchange
with other people exactly like me
because i can predict exactly what
you're going to do next because i know
exactly what i'm going to do next time
doing it
so you know we could be singing or
talking together clearly we take turns
but
there are situations where we could be
actually singing in the choir together
but i can only sing with people that
have a sufficiently similar generative
model to me that makes it
that licenses the use of my model
of how this kind of creature interacts
with the world
uh license licenses its use
as a model of how you are interacting
with the world and are interacting with
interacting with me so that's what i
meant by shared narrative just
just a shared or a conserved generative
model
between um creatures that typically
um act together in terms of things like
joint attention or
familial bonds or sort of con specifics
in an evolutionary
context um you know
the generalizes um in terms of your
cultural takes on
um niche construction you know
the the existence of things like signs
and traffic lights and elephant and
desire paths
these are all manifestations of um you
know
living sharing a world with other
creatures like myself
that after a while there they become
very
efficient very simple ways of
communicating that possibly as you say
don't involve
spoken language and non-verbal
communication um
is clearly an incredibly important part
of that but even beyond that
just the fact that we have a shared
commitment to
stopping when a traffic signal or light
goes red
you know that's a shared narrative we
have that enables us to drive around and
occupy the same streets
when some of us are driving and some of
those are walking or both of us are
driving
so that's what i meant by shared
narrative is sort of you know a common
a common generative model of how to live
in this world
with things like me
you